For
Wednesday.
This is my,
our first Yates lecture.
We're going to have three of them,
uh,
for the next class.
I'd like you to,
um,
uh,
well,
I'd like you to do a few things.
Um,
I know that,
uh,
you're teaching fellows will have handed out a meter exercise for you.
Uh,
I'd like you to,
um,
uh,
working on something else.
You don't have to do this for Wednesday,
but let's say for next Monday.
Uh,
and that,
that is,
I'd like you to memorize a short poem by,
um,
Yates or by frost,
either one.
Uh,
and this poem could be the basis of a first paper,
a topic for one.
It doesn't have to be,
uh,
but it,
it might be an aisle.
On Wednesday.
I'll also handout,
um,
a topic for paper one,
uh,
in,
in class.
I'll talk about,
uh,
eastern 1916,
the magpie,
the second coming later in the swan.
Uh,
and I'd like you to pay special attention to these special [inaudible] words to
molt turbulence,
be steel.
Uh,
think about also that phrase,
terrible beauty in eastern 1916.
Uh,
and finally in your Ras packet,
you'll see a,
a timeline,
um,
that,
uh,
um,
charts oh,
uh,
significant dates,
um,
in,
in modern poetry that that tells you something about,
uh,
when,
the different poets were reading were working,
uh,
in helps you,
perhaps,
uh,
keep track of them because confusingly,
although the course has a kind of rough,
chronological order,
uh,
we do move back and forth in time.
Uh,
and in fact today,
right now,
uh,
we're going to move back the furthest we go,
all the way until the 19th century to talk about the early Yates Yates.
His career is,
is maybe the most famous one in modern poetry,
uh,
that is,
career,
uh,
that has been seen as a,
as a kind of representative story about modern poetry as a whole.
Uh,
what's that story?
Well,
uh,
Yates begins as a,
as a romantic visionary,
uh,
and,
I'm kind of late 19th century aesthete and under the pressure of political and
social crisis,
he breaks with the artificial rhetoric of his early poems and becomes a kind of
heroic realist.
Uh,
now there,
there's something,
uh,
to this story.
Uh,
but it is also a kind of cliche and,
and uh,
I'll try to try to introduce a,
I think a more true,
uh,
and also more interesting way of understanding Yates as development today
starting with this picture.
Uh,
this is,
this is an unlikely picture that the,
the face there,
uh,
if you,
have seen him before you will recognize as Yates is,
uh,
this is,
this is Yates,
uh,
as King Gall.
This is Yates in costume
costumes as a figure from Irish myth,
uh,
as an ancient bard,
a mad king gall,
uh,
which is,
which is the furthest thing from a modern poet.
Uh,
it's a late Victorian image of an archaic singer,
a rendered in the melodramatic manner of pre-raphaelite art and thoroughly
removed from the aesthetic values of modernism such as naturalism,
formal clarity,
emotional restraint,
and so on.
Uh,
it's an image that was created by Yates's father,
uh,
the painter John Yates.
Uh,
you could also say that it was created by the late 19th century culture that
Yates is father John represented and introduced to his son.
It's an image of Yates that modern poetry,
uh,
eventually forgot a Yates as an unmodern 19th century poet,
hamming it up.
Uh,
but this poet is in fact important,
uh,
to the one that Yates became.
Uh,
in a way,
Yates is always in costume.
Uh,
his poetic identity is forged through identification with the heroic characters
of his poems,
uh,
characters who are sometimes surrogates for the poets such as King Gaul.
Now the warrior Coolin a or the mysterious Michael Rebar Taiz,
uh,
all characters,
you will meet a or who are sometimes simply versions of the poet himself.
Um,
that is,
uh,
the poet rendering himself for us in stylized roles.
That is Yates,
the public man,
Yates,
the lover,
the mad old man.
A Yates is always creating himself in his poems,
uh,
and creating himself as a kind of a version of a type A.
And he does the same thing.
In fact to those around him,
uh,
famously to,
his lover,
Maude Gunn,
who becomes Helen of Troy,
uh,
in,
in no second Troy and in other poems,
uh,
the martyrs in the Easter rebellion of 1916 become ancient Irish warriors.
We'll talk about that next time.
There are many other instances of this kind of myth making a imagination that
Yates,
uh,
is always working with Yates,
takes on self,
consciously staged a identities,
uh,
requiring costumes,
any sees other people in similarly theatrical and mythic terms.
His poetry is in fact,
deeply autobiographical.
Uh,
but it doesn't necessarily help to,
to know that,
uh,
because his life is,
is not a reliable key for reading the poems.
Exactly.
Because he treated his life,
uh,
as art,
raising the particulars of his,
uh,
experience,
into,
uh,
well general symbols,
working the narrative of his life into a,
uh,
into,
into myth.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
a way of conceiving his activity as a poet.
Uh,
but it's also as we'll see,
a way of conceiving in fact,
culture and human history in general in Yates,
uh,
people are always,
particulars who are fitted to types,
which are new versions of old identities that travel across time.
Uh,
in a,
in a certain sense,
uh,
Yates I think really felt that he was King Gaul.
Now the story of Kangol is interesting.
It's a longish poem,
a not in your anthology,
but you can find it in the complete Yates.
And I've given you on this handout page,
uh,
just a couple,
stands stanzas from it.
Uh,
so you have a,
a sense of it.
Uh,
King Gall is as a mythical Irish ruler who goes mad in the heat of battle.
He becomes distracted by an inward fire,
uh,
that draws him into the woods where he wanders and sings full of unfulfilled
desire.
Uh,
finally he destroys his harp and the scene represented by Yates's fathers
portrait.
This story is,
uh,
a certain version of Yates's own early ambition to become a particular kind of
figure,
not an Irish king,
but in Irish poet,
which would mean consolidating in him sense in himself,
a sense of national identity and explaining that identity,
uh,
representing it,
embodying it in all senses,
uh,
um,
representing and embodying Irishness for an English speaking readership,
uh,
in Ireland,
but also in England and elsewhere.
The nationality of that identity is important.
That is Yates is Irishness.
Uh,
and so is Yates is audience.
his ambition is to become the first major Irish poet writing in English.
Uh,
significantly.
this picture of,
of Yates is king gall was used as an illustration for his first appearance in an
English periodical,
a magazine of art and ideas called the leisure hour.
Uh,
you Yates is,
uh,
Yates,
bridges,
Irish and English cultures,
uh,
any is importantly Protestant,
with social and family ties to English life.
The ambition that I'm describing as it is a public and political one.
Uh,
but,
uh,
paradoxically,
perhaps for the young Yates,
this ambition drew him away from the social and political world,
uh,
into the charm.
The landscapes of Irish myth,
uh,
maybe in the same way or,
as king gall is,
is drawn away from,
lured away from battle,
uh,
to wander in the Irish would,
all of Yates' early poetry takes place in a symbolic mythic domain.
King galls madness in the destruction of his instruments are,
are perhaps,
uh,
warnings about the dangers of a poetry that would be confined to a symbolic
world,
uh,
as if to fully enter it,
to fully enter mythical world,
to write a kind of pure poetry,
uh,
that was archaic in,
in its aims and its sources.
This would be to go mad,
uh,
to give suede of dangerously inward passions,
that can't be satisfied to be cut off from the world,
uh,
being cut off from the world in some kind of higher or separate reality is a
lure and threat,
uh,
opened up,
for Yates by the,
uh,
particular ambition,
that he had to write a mythic poetry on Irish themes.
Uh,
now something else a is worth highlighting about king gall,
uh,
as a way to understand who Yates was.
A KANGOL is a singer,
a identifying with him.
Uh,
Yates identifies poetry with song,
uh,
in particular,
with songs of passion,
uh,
in which songs in which sound takes over,
is ravishing and chanting.
Yates' early poetry has those aspects of song as its aim.
They suggest a verbal and an oral equivalents for the poetry's cognitive concern
with symbols that is,
uh,
in sound,
just as in theme.
Yates is poetry is idealized,
purified,
centrally rich,
uh,
and yet also abstract contrast.
Frost Yates is poetry dominated the poetry world in which frost began writing
and publishing a Yates publishes King Gall in the leisure hour.
Uh,
and frost mocks the Po mocks the ideal of poetry as the dream of the gift of
idle hours.
Uh,
he mocks the idea of poetry as easy gold,
uh,
at the hand of Fei or Elf in,
in mowing,
uh,
characters that,
that come right out of early Yates frosts realism,
uh,
his roughness,
which you,
which is part of his sensibility.
It's part of the sound of his poetry.
Um,
well,
uh,
it contrast quite directly with the,
smoothness,
uh,
sought by Yates and the,
the,
the kind of a simulation of,
of ease.
Uh,
you could,
you could go to,
um,
uh,
yeats's poem Adam's curse to see the poet,
um,
uh,
talking about this,
aesthetic ideal Yates,
uh,
there,
in Adam's curse,
which is in your anthology,
uh,
cost specifically for,
for kind of a simulation of,
of ease,
uh,
in poetry,
which is a traditionally aristocratic ideal one which hides,
uh,
one's labor in order to make accomplishments seem natural.
Uh,
Yates,
a in Adam's curse,
uh,
regrets that the beautiful is something to be labored for.
Uh,
any wants to conceal that Labor.
the contrast with Frost is,
is this powerful.
Gates once said that he wanted the natural words in the natural order,
but he had a very highly cultured sense of what is natural.
Uh,
and his poetry is,
is full of,
of verbal archaism.
Uh,
it's characterized by kind of high formal bearing.
it's,
uh,
has a careful decor.
I'm a kind of high sheen,
especially this early poetry,
uh,
metrically Yates is,
attitudes result in a kind of superb regularity,
uh,
in early,
Yates.
You find smooth,
unbroken lines,
diction that's elegant and seemingly easy,
uh,
without,
every,
every deigning to seem merely colloquial.
Uh,
the sound of Yates was,
uh,
and was meant to be seductive.
Uh,
the poems are in fact very often about,
about kinds of seduction.
A child,
a king,
the poet.
These figures are drawn away from society or from family towards secret sacred
places,
uh,
magical places of love,
that are frequently imaged in these poems as an island or the center of a wood,
uh,
in short,
places of privacy that,
that shut the world out in that stand for Yates is ideal of poetic autonomy.
His desire to create and inhabit self-sufficient,
imaginative worlds.
The lake isle of Innisfree who goes with Fergus,
uh,
the hosting of the,
she,
uh,
the,
these are all poems,
uh,
from your anthology that exemplify this,
idea.
Uh,
and there are many,
many more.
Um,
the,
uh,
these pumps,
come from a phase in the eights,
his career,
the climax of which is this book published in 1,899 that I showed you the cover
of,
and the first class,
the wind among the reeds with,
it's a gorgeous Celtic,
uh,
aestheticism,
here.
It's the,
uh,
the,
title page reminding us again that this gorgeous Celtic aestheticism,
uh,
is,
published and put up for sale in London.
Uh,
which is important again.
and,
and here is a,
the table of contents which you can't read,
but has a on it.
Uh,
uh,
well,
the first poem,
the hosting of the,
she,
uh,
the,
a song of Wandering Angus,
uh,
and other,
famous palms from Yates is early career.
I'd like to look with you at the song,
the wandering Angus as a,
as a kind of model of the kind of poem I'm talking about.
And it's the aesthetics.
It's on Nine
v eight.
He ate,
says,
I went out to the Hazelwood.
Okay.
Gate says,
that is to say,
Angus says it's a dramatic monologue for Angus.
I went out to the Hazelwood because a fire was in my head and cut and peeled a
hazel wand and hooked to Barry to a thread.
If you're having problems identifying I ambit pentameter,
this should,
well,
it's not,
not quite pentameter,
but if you want,
I want to get an eye Ambika um,
rhythm in your head.
This will do it.
Uh,
and cut and peeled.
A Hazel won and hook to Barry to a thread and when white mobs were on the wing
and moth like stars were flickering out,
I dropped the berry in a stream and caught a little silver trout
when I had laid it on the floor.
I went to blow the fire of flame,
but something wrestled on the floor and someone called me by my name.
It had become a glimmering girl with apple blossom in her hair,
who called me by my name and ran and faded through the brightening air.
Though I am old with wandering through hollow lands and Healy Lands,
I will find out where she has gone and kiss her lips and take her hands and walk
among long dappled grass and pluck till time.
And Times are done.
The silver apples of the moon,
the golden apples of the sun,
it's rhymed.
I am Vick Tet travitor four beats per line with some variations.
Uh,
it is a popular song form a in English.
it's the way Puck,
uh,
and uh,
other,
um,
uh,
folk characters speak,
in Shakespeare.
It's smoothness in its simplicity,
uh,
is associated with folk forms.
Uh,
perhaps with the condition of enchantment,
we're trance into which the speaker Angus falls.
The poem is a fairy tale.
It's a story of Angus is longing and quest for union with a fairy girl whom he
desires.
Yates spoke of the poem as a mad song.
Uh,
that's maybe not I kind of mad song.
We would,
um,
we isn't that what we would think of as a mad song necessarily.
Uh,
the poem imagines,
uh,
through a dramatic character,
Yates his own coming to poetry,
which he represents here,
both as the undertaking of a specifically erotic quest,
uh,
and as a sort of fury in the mind,
a fire was in my head and gets begins.
Yates wants us to share in as we attend to the sound of his poem,
a certain state of enchantment and longing,
which includes a feeling of monotony.
As we listened to those repeated phrases and images and syntactic structures
that always seem on the verge of redundance in this poem,
I think about how generalized,
how abstract,
how unnatural nature is in this poem.
But then it's exactly a poem about nature transformed.
Uh,
the fish who turns into the glimmering girl who,
uh,
like any really marvelous cat gets away,
the transformation here,
uh,
importantly interrupts the eating of the fruit.
Consummation of desire is deferred.
Appetite,
gets sublimated and at the same time deferred held in suspension.
The glimmering girl then,
cause Angus by name,
she names him.
She in a sense makes him Angus Angus is the Celtic name.
Uh,
the Celtic,
uh,
the Celtic master of love,
a certain kind of Irish version of Apollo.
Uh,
he's also a mortal who ages the palm,
describes a vocational moment,
uh,
when the poet is called to his calling,
called to,
it's calling in in a way that amounts to a kind of seduction that lures him out
into the woods wandering,
uh,
as he follows this fish woman,
and fairy girl,
uh,
who is a kind of Muse or mother to,
the quest is without end.
It's even without direction.
Uh,
uh,
it has,
a goal,
however that's described in that last stanza,
contrast.
Yates is old age and the,
the,
the freshness of his desire in this poem,
uh,
he holds in dream the possibility of satisfied desire,
possession of the beloved,
meaning specifically physical possession of her,
which would be an apocalyptic event.
The end of time and times a Yates represents that moment of consummation as the
plucking of the silver and the gold apples.
Yates was chained in the occult disciplines of theosophy and Gnosticism.
Those,
uh,
traditions,
merge in his early work with European symbolism.
Uh,
and also with the Irish cultural national nationalism.
Here,
the gold and silver apples are specifically al chemical symbols of body and
soul,
uh,
and a kind of mystical image of a earthly paradise.
It's a nice touch.
Uh,
uh,
but don't worry about these symbols.
It don't worry about them too much.
Uh,
here as elsewhere in Yates is poetry.
Um,
it's not essential for you to be able to,
uh,
pursue his a cult learning and decode his symbols in order to read his poetry.
Uh,
Johanne Ramezani who is the editor of the Norton,
uh,
and,
great Yates and uh,
uh,
he's,
he himself has decided that all of this is too much to explain and you don't
really need it.
Uh,
and fair enough.
The point is simply to recognize that the apples are a cult symbols,
uh,
which is to say they're not apples.
They are rather images,
symbols,
artifacts,
uh,
and isn't that clear already from their colors,
the material that they're made of gold and silver.
Uh,
these colors mark them as fashioned precious objects,
inorganic,
uh,
and,
and all these ways beyond time in nature,
growth or decay when Angus or Yates,
uh,
pursue their desires,
the object of desire that is,
uh,
when they,
when they pursue a kind of hope for unity of being that the merging with the
beloved would constitute this carries them out of the natural world into a realm
of high art of symbols.
The realization of desire for this young Yates is something only possible in art
in many ways.
Uh,
retained this aesthetic bias.
this is Yates,
uh,
rather,
later,
uh,
still dressed.
However,
uh,
in his study,
as,
uh,
an aesthete and dandy.
Uh,
you can see that,
that,
uh,
wonderful,
coat m and a silk bow tie.
Uh,
he began and ended his career as a decadent,
uh,
I suppose,
a reader of Walter pater and Oscar Wilde.
Uh,
nonetheless,
uh,
Oscar Wilde,
a friend of Yeats.
Nonetheless,
Yates is poetry does undergo an important and notable,
a stylistic change.
When I said that there's a story about Yates is career that makes him out to be
an exemplary modern poet.
Uh,
I had in mind,
uh,
how over the course of this long career,
he leaves behind him,
that idealized world of late 19th century art,
uh,
for a more fully human realist poetry.
Uh,
one that rhetorically strips away Yates's own poetic systems,
uh,
and locates his subjects in contemporary politics and history.
This is,
this is the,
uh,
the,
the kind of,
uh,
generalized story of Yates has career pound.
Ezra pound is Yates is younger friend pound you'll see,
keeps turning up and all of these stories.
Uh,
he had a role in,
in pushing Yates in the direction in which he went.
Uh,
he had also a big role in public eighth of development.
here's the,
a copy of a letter to pound by Yates,
uh,
when they were both living in London.
Uh,
this is at the [inaudible],
uh,
among,
um,
pounds papers.
Um,
the,
uh,
oh,
here's the,
this is,
this is Yates is letter.
Uh,
he's living at this point,
uh,
at,
Wellborn place.
Uh,
Yates is in London,
uh,
where one of the bombs went off in London two summers ago.
A write up right outside his house.
My dear pound here is the poem.
Many thanks for
taking so much trouble with it.
Yours,
a WB Yeats,
uh,
pound goes to work on Yates.
Uh,
it goes to work on his,
uh,
poetry and helps modernize him.
Uh,
although I think in lots of ways the influence went just as much.
The other way,
the period of pounds influenced,
coincides with Yates is significantly titled Book,
uh,
representation of skin representations,
responsibilities rather.
Uh,
this is published in 1914,
which is the same year as frosts north of Boston.
And these two books are coming out the same moment in London.
Uh,
some of the poems in this book dramatize a dramatize and describe the stylistic
changes I'm talking about.
For instance,
uh,
the short poem,
a coat.
Uh,
here it is.
It's in your,
um,
anthology as well.
I made my song a coat covered with embroidery's out of old mythologies from heel
to throat.
But the fool caught it,
wore it in the world's eye as though they'd brought it song.
Let them take it for there's more enterprise in walking naked.
This is a,
uh,
Yates's Yates is throwing off his early work as if throwing off a kind of
costume.
All that King Golf crap that he had on,
he sees tossing it off.
Uh,
the embroidery and decoration,
all that now seems inauthentic.
Uh,
something that in fact the aids his audience had failed to value properly.
He's complaining here in this poem,
a short poem he's referring to.
Um,
the,
uh,
vexed efforts,
by himself.
Uh,
and,
uh,
his collaborators,
JM sing and Lady Augusta Gregory,
uh,
to create an Irish national theater.
Uh,
Yates,
uh,
sought a popular audience for his poetry,
impart through,
uh,
his work in the theater.
Buddy became disenchanted with the theater going public,
uh,
with imitators and detractors to,
all of whom as he puts it here,
caught at his coat.
Uh,
this is a poem that declares nakedness as a,
as a poetic,
uh,
as a point of value.
Uh,
it's a kind of semi official announcement,
but Yates is,
is giving up his early manner,
uh,
precisely because it seems like a manner,
and a disguise in doing so.
Yates might've seemed to be moving closer to the Irish people in a move,
something like frosts for swearing of the poetry of dream,
uh,
and elves and fairies in favor of a poetry of fact,
in,
and,
uh,
let's keep in mind for us own wish to create a poetry that would reach ordinary
people,
uh,
and would reach,
all kinds and sorts.
Uh,
again,
it might seem that Yates,
uh,
is interested in something like this too.
And again,
the same moment that that frost is publishing his work in,
uh,
England,
but there's a difference in Yates.
He adopts this ideal of nakedness precisely,
uh,
as a repudiation of a popular audience.
It's a kind of dare,
uh,
demonstrating not just his indifference to the crowd,
but in fact is scorn for it.
I'm going to walk naked.
I'm not going to dress for you.
Uh,
Yates' early poetry is elite,
uh,
because it is high aristocratic,
ideal in character.
The middle poetry,
the poetry that begins with the volume responsibilities remains elite.
Uh,
only now it's a lead is and will be expressed differently.
It will be expressed in a rhetoric of nakedness or what Yates we'll also call
coldness.
Uh,
the fishermen.
The fishermen is another poem from this volume,
uh,
that both comments on and,
and,
uh,
exemplifies the transformation that I'm describing.
Uh,
the transformation of [inaudible] style and values.
Um,
it's suggests both the difference between the earlier Yates and the Middle
Yates,
uh,
but also,
importantly the kinds of continuity between them,
the ways in which Yates remained very much the same poet.
Let me read it for you.
Hmm.
Although I can see him still.
The freckled man who goes to a gray place on a hill in gray,
Connemara close
at dawn to cast his flies.
It's long since I began to call up to the eyes this wise and simple man
all day I'd looked in the face what I had hoped to would be to write for my own
race.
And the reality,
the living men that I hate,
the dead man,
that I loved,
the crave and man in his seat,
the insolent unwrap proved in no nave brought to book who has won the drunk and
cheer the Witty Man and his joke aimed at the commonest ear
and the clever man who cries the catch cries of the clown.
The beating down of the wise and great art beaten down
well Yates begins in scorn of an audience that's unable to recognize true wisdom
and great art.
Uh,
in scoring of that audience,
uh,
he imagines another audience,
another audience to write for and to emulate and audience represented by the
fishermen.
Uh,
what is the fishermen like?
What does he represent?
Uh,
what,
uh,
values does he embody
grayness,
uh,
that suggests the color of a land,
and uh,
culture.
Uh,
the color of stone,
uh,
of peasant close,
he,
the fishermen,
uh,
is a solitary figure in,
in a landscape of stone stone that is dark,
uh,
resistant,
apparently non ideal.
That is real,
uh,
contrast this place,
this way of imagining Ireland.
Ireland means,
uh,
with the sensual landscape of Angus,
with the reality of the world of that earlier poem.
Uh,
in a sense,
the earlier poem,
the Song of Wandering Angus,
uh,
transformed,
the Irish landscape into a place of myth
in the same way that the poem is
describing the transformation of the trout into the girl
Yates seems to be reversing this trick in the fishermen,
uh,
seems to be converting myth back into reality.
Uh,
the ideal object of desire,
uh,
from a glimmering girl back into a trout.
It's a,
the poem represents a kind of,
uh,
as,
as the,
the short poem,
a coat represents a kind of ascetic move,
inactive,
imaginative in rhetorical stripping down the landscape itself,
uh,
in,
um,
here in,
in yeats's poem seems naked,
a barren probably until Ebel.
Uh,
and the poetry that Yates wants from this place,
uh,
will be as it seems as he goes on to describe cold,
and passionate.
Let me finish the poem here.
Maybe a 12 month sense.
Suddenly I began in scoring of this audience that Yates has been describing,
this audience associated with the double and middle class and theater going
public in scorn of this audience.
Uh,
I began imagining a man and his son freckled face and gray Connemara cloth
climbing up to a place where stone is dark under froth in the downturn of his
wrist.
When the flies drop in the stream,
a man who does not exist,
a man who is but a dream and cried before I'm old,
I shall have written him one poem.
Maybe it's cold and passionate as the dawn,
the poetry that,
that,
uh,
Yates wants from this place,
place that the fishermen takes him to,
uh,
is a,
it's going to be cold and,
and passionate as he describes it.
You can see him in a sense.
It's a cooling the fire in the head of Angus,
uh,
at this moment,
the palm identifies also cold and passion with dawn.
Uh,
the moment of awakening,
which is also a moment of,
of coming into reality from,
from dream and,
and sleep.
Uh,
Yates is the kind of rhetorical and stylistic transformation I'm describing,
uh,
identified with,
with Yates as modernness,
uh,
his,
his coming into a modernity.
All Ha ha,
Ha has these qualities,
uh,
in,
as associated here.
You powerfully with,
with morning
importantly though,
uh,
morning and dawn are also seen as moments of passionate,
if Angus is a figure of passion.
So interestingly is the fishermen.
It's only what it means to,
uh,
to write a poetry of passion that Yates is now beginning to rethink.
Passion seems to lie and coldness rather than heat,
uh,
lies exactly in the restraining,
in disciplining of passion.
Uh,
in this sense,
uh,
the fishermen is not after all a poem that's very different from the song of
wandering Angus.
In fact,
Yates is still writing about a solitary fishermen.
And,
uh,
just as in that earlier palm,
the act of fishing is symbolically resonant.
The fishermen is an image of man,
uh,
searching the depths of the world for the wisdom that hides beneath the surface
of things.
Uh,
the,
uh,
fishing is seen here as in the earlier poem as an image of quest,
in a,
uh,
an image of desire
for all these reasons.
Uh,
the fishermen is really a rewriting,
uh,
and,
even a kind of a continuation rather than a repudiation of the song of wandering
Angus.
And the poems from that period,
uh,
in fact,
as Yates declares
the fishermen does not exist.
It's a wonderful sentence,
isn't it?
Uh,
a man who does not exist,
a man who is,
but a dream Yates is still writing dream.
Uh,
uh,
the man is not a real man.
The man is a symbol only this time,
a symbol of the real,
a symbol of the actual and local of the Irish race in the reality and the poetry
that he stands for,
that the fishermen stands for it like all of Yates.
His poetry is a poetry again,
of symbols.
Uh,
the fishermen is also representative of the Irish peasant tree,
uh,
to,
to whom Yates turns,
uh,
in scorn of the urban audience that he had tried to write for in the theater.
This is again,
not a break with the aristocratic values of the early poetry,
but at an aligning of those values with an ideal image of the peasant classes,
uh,
with whom,
Yates,
uh,
creates a kind of imaginative bond against the bourgeois people who seem to
represent the new order of things.
Uh,
modernity a and Dublin,
uh,
Yates,
a sense of,
of,
uh,
um,
of modern history,
uh,
of the crisis of his,
this is something we can describe,
uh,
and explore next time and eastern 1916.
Uh,
before we finish today,
uh,
let me just,
connect
the fishermen and it's a images of a cold passion,
uh,
to,
um,
uh,
another,
um,
poem.
Um,
the,
uh,
um,
well,
specifically the,
um,
uh,
log for Robert Gregory.
Uh,
yeah,
it's,
um,
a friend,
Augustus Gregory's son,
uh,
who,
dies in the first world war.
An airman,
a Yates,
uh,
here,
evokes Gregory as a kind of,
um,
uh,
fallen,
representative of Irish culture and of Aristocratic Culture in particular,
uh,
in which art and eloquence and,
political and cultural life all coexist.
And all,
uh,
combine and form a passionate heart.
Um,
Yates,
uh,
evokes Gregory's death and,
and sees,
uh,
it,
in relation to,
uh,
other,
friends and collaborators of,
uh,
Yates as early life,
including Lionel Johnson and sing,
uh,
and,
and others.
Um,
this is,
uh,
again,
Gregory representing a kind of,
uh,
aristocratic,
elegance,
uh,
and,
and a culture that is,
uh,
juxtaposed to,
will be juxtaposed to the,
uh,
um,
revolutionary violence that,
uh,
comes to
shatter the Irish capital,
uh,
in,
1916.
Uh,
and in many ways a reshape Yates his career as he,
uh,
encounters,
what he calls a,
the terrible beauty of that.
Um,
uh,
explosive,
rebellion.
Well,
uh,
that's enough for today.
Uh,
and we'll continue with EHS on Wednesday.